tu quittes la maison sans dire au revoir
aux enfants public a besoin de s'isoler
de réfléchir
ni complètement désaccordé j'suis pas un
coin et qu'est ce qu'il ya là où il faut
pas monter
donc tu peux me passer les enfants
s'appellent ils sont pas là
tu es avec keira
[Musique]
bon c'est juste une petite crise
d'angoissé
maintenant et on coucher pendant deux
trois jours mais pas plus sain et
surtout pas de mélange avec ça
c'est super beau c'est très calme tu
peux m'expliquer apporter pense à moi
quand tu passes ta maîtresse
il est bien ta femme pas vraiment un
conte
est ce que tu fais là toi t'as pas
encore couchés maintenant il ya une
vraie nuit
voilà maintenant il fait nuit
on va bien dit que le piano seraient
accordés et c'est pas le cas ah bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement qu'est ce qui te fait penser
que je couche avec ton pote pourquoi tu
fais ça parce que c'est concret
l'histoire je suis venu ici pour
l'isoler
excuse moi mon amour mais l'artiste en
panne d'inspiration qui part s'isoler un
cliché à
[Musique]
l'orée de faire un enfant pour en
arriver là
[Musique]
faut que tu apprennes à accepter
certaines choses de tard
est victime de toi même
tu veux quelque chose qui n'existe pas
à temps
j'ai l'impression que ça me fait du bien
de rêver
[Musique]
oh